hey you guys time really sidetrack it's
Thursday today yeah hopefully you guys
have been enjoying the witching hour I
put up earlier yeah mad science stories
we watched some [ __ ] last night [ __ ]
had me now don't go too much into it cuz
we're gonna review it for the matinee
show we finished watching Tiger King
yeah guys you guys have you guys seen
you guys this is the craziest [ __ ] you
have ever seen and like everybody it's
just it was one of those things like I
really like like Netflix is really good
with their like true crime documentary
she's like you know a lot of more
serious and stuff like that which you
know that's fine this one these people
it's like you think that it can't get
crazier or more unexpected because I
didn't know much about this case I'd
heard but that guy like Joe exotic but
that was about all I knew I didn't know
about all the [ __ ] I didn't know about
this [ __ ] with Carroll Baskin like the
big cat rescue lady and so and so it's
just seemed like each episode it just
got more and more outlandish and you
just couldn't [ __ ] believe it turns
out it is all true it's all true and
these all the main players are like the
worst people ever they're all terrible
everyone's terrible yesterday I I
mentioned that you know some people
might might use the term white trash and
I said no waste trash I don't know if
I'm my backup off I design just white
people have a certain expectations we
expect those of our kind be able to meet
a certain standard if not I was feeling
[ __ ] embarrassed
I was just putting my head as well.these
I mean I mean to their credit like
pretty much every because I watched like
some other reviews a bit like earlier
today just out of curiosity and this is
Laura de well diplomat well yeah they
were in both way actually what some of
it took place in the yeah okay but yeah
most of the reviews most people said the
same thing it's like they could not
believe it's like what planet are all of
these people from and it's like this is
and you know most are said this is the
most batshit insane thing you will ever
see it's like none of the people are
likable like some of the like you know
people around the periphery like friends
of the main people those people are like
they just don't make any goddamn sense
no these are like all insane people
they're all the same people every person
in the guys just is terrible and insane
but in a really entertaining way oh yes
it is a very entertaining you just can't
believe it like I said we don't want to
go to you what you do it should be in it
cuz I want to review it for the bad days
you're seeing it and it just doesn't
[ __ ] make sense that's what I mean
it's like eating yeah you're like I
can't believe you it's like people like
that like walking around yeah it's too
much [ __ ] you're just like no this is
people aren't really like this and it's
not fake it's [ __ ] real and people
were killed in the film and people
actually go to prison in this [ __ ] like
I said it's it's technically a true
crime series and the animals were harmed
yeah yeah they don't show it but yeah I
was I was happy about that because like
I said the little warning thing says
animal harm and I'm like no it's about
these show all the people Harvey wants
yeah it's just about these cliques of
people they were here in Florida first
cliques of people that [ __ ] raised
we're in the big cat business but
there's no there's not supposed to be a
big cat business it's illegal sale cats
and things associated with cats like
kafir and chili you're not supposed to
be able to sell that or deal with that
but they find ways it just renamed [ __ ]
yeah like cat sanctuary might be it says
cat sanctuary on it but it might be cat
breeding factory is what it really is
yeah and they're selling that [ __ ] out
the backdoor and bad [ __ ] was happening
sometimes and then they're like they're
like opposing cults that are all pretty
much exactly alike even though they all
[ __ ] hate each other
yeah and they all accuse they all accuse
each other of doing what they're doing
and there's a bunch of [ __ ] people
come up missing and people get killed
and one guy's back they're [ __ ]
around one one of the real famous dudes
of multi multi-millionaire who is kind
of like Florida's version of [ __ ]
Tony Montana he was he was dealing in
cocaine he had a cocaine Empire and most
of the cocaine was just used to fuel his
addiction to [ __ ] exotic animals he's
in it you know he talked about chopping
up dead
chopping up dudes you have to kill him
and she he goes even to president got
out it's just yeah it's it's a real
thing that dude was the sane one oh yeah
Dan I've seen several other reviews say
that it's like he was like pretty much
there he was a yeah the only likable man
yeah the damn drug the ex-drug dealer
[ __ ] my future's only wanna make my
goddamn sense the other one didn't make
any [ __ ] sense
they're all lunatic yeah yeah well like
I said well you know we went into it
some there but we'll review it on Sunday
because I've done will be the second
thing I review I want to review a Mary
ante which I finished and it was
actually really really good and I think
tonight I have to find a third thing I
think shudder just added a new horror
movie that I've been hearing about
called Daniel isn't real
so I will probably be reviewing that one
as well because I can watch that this
evening after we finish recording so um
what was I gonna say oh and also like I
said I finished I recorded some more
stories for the next witching hour show
which will go up next Thursday I'm not
gonna say what the theme is but one of
the stories was Edgar Allen Poe's
hopfrog
so I thought that since I hadn't done
book recommendations in the last couple
and since we were talking about animals
because of that batshit crazy tiger King
show I wanted to recommend a couple of
non-fiction books about animals that are
actually really kick-ass
this first one and I love this [ __ ]
book I've read it two or three times
it's called the mind of the Raven by
Bernd Heinrich and he is an
ornithologist
and he has this book is amazing because
I knew that like crows and ravens at
Corbett's as they call them were really
intelligent not even just as birds ago
but as animals in general ago but the
[ __ ] that he did because he has a whole
like Raven enclosure like in his house
so he can study them all the time it's
just like he has a window that opens out
into this big like huge enclosure and he
devises like all these like tests and
stuff for them and the [ __ ] that they
can do some of the [ __ ] that they can do
is stuff that like monkeys can't figure
out how to do yeah one thing one thing
that Ravens doing maybe a lot of people
know this because they have videos of
them doing it they can't just use tools
they can make a tool for a specific
purpose yeah like you can build like he
built like these things that he would
put food like so that you would have to
have a tool that was like curved and
then he just gave him like all these
tools that were straight and they
figured out how to like make they took
the wires and stuff and made like a
[ __ ] curved thing so they can get the
thing in there which leads you to
believe since you know holy cruisers are
like the living descendants of dinosaurs
may have been the dinosaurs are pretty
smart yeah it's like I always feel like
because when I was a kid I was really
into dinosaurs what are you doing focus
is about um I always heard that like
dinosaurs were really dumb but I don't
know if that's the case I mean maybe the
really big ones were down because they
were just like you know mostly they
grazed and stuff yeah they had herd
animals and prey but I feel like the
smaller ones like your Velociraptor
types were probably super intelligent
because weren't they pack hunters
usually they have to be smart to be
packing they had brains the size of a
dog yeah so and it's like cats and dogs
are pretty smart imagine if that was a
damn birdbrain that size probably pretty
smart yeah yeah well you know we don't
know what the [ __ ] cells look like
you know I mean what the brain cells
look like houses arranged yeah I managed
to do it the interconnectivity between
all those dudes are saying it's like
they know not so much the amount of yeah
I mean they used to say that like you
know the ratio brain to body size you
know was a factor but I don't know if
that's really a factor anymore because
like I said a lot of birds particularly
crows are way way way more intelligent
they even do more intelligent [ __ ] they
like monkeys or dogs and stuff and their
brains are like really small notice
those damn hunting spiders they're
little bitty hunting spiders they have a
damn brain the size of a salt crystal
and they're planning ahead
yeah and trying to conceive they're
trying to you know try to see a path to
something that's quite complicated and
they can get there see that I always
freak you because the thing about
spiders is that to make a web that
intricate um you know I can see how like
making like say the orb web you know
your standard orb web you know that
could be like instinct or whatever but
it's like you're not gonna be always
making it in the same environment and
you don't really know like what the
angles are for everything and how is the
best thing but it seems like they always
kind of do it yeah and there's not much
there in terms of brain cells those
little little bitty tiny ants that you
could barely see do all kinds of
complicated [ __ ] they don't really
hardly have a brain yeah I'm like bees
and stuff teacher you know Stuart
Hameroff he would say well it's not the
brain it's that damn quantum field that
surrounds the brain that they're all
kind of like that yeah yeah that you
know maybe in religion that you called a
soul or a consciousness or you know what
I mean oh or a sensation of being being
in a place you know that that place
where you are that that's that doing it
not so much the the brain the brain is
just organizing that you know or as we
said it could be something to do with
the interconnectivity between yeah I
think that's one factor is the brain but
Hameroff was saying there's more to it
than that there's because the brain is
kind of digital in a certain way but
around it there's [ __ ] there's a quantum
field of [ __ ] have what he call them
so it's a it's they're in superposition
and interconnected no no outside that
outside that there's a there's some kind
of a quantum field of consciousness that
is around the brain that the brain is
kind of Janna
it's kind of weird yeah and you know as
I said I kind of feel like a lot of
animals are a lot smarter than they're
given any given credit for I mean
particularly because do you remember
when we were growing up and stuff like
that people would say [ __ ] about I mean
I think people have always thought that
dogs were fairly intelligent because you
know they're very um people-pleasing um
but I I felt like maybe cats got sort of
like [ __ ] Oh a little bit for not being
a smarter or and I feel like a lot of
people thought that animals couldn't
plan ahead in the same sense that a
person can but I think that's crap I see
her plan she plans ahead all the time
yeah she sees when the bowls empty and
she tells me to fill that and she
doesn't want it right now yeah and she
eats it later she wants it later she
just she just wants to check and make
sure that it's there especially for her
to have lease leave before we go to
sleep she's like hey yeah hey wait a
minute wait a minute yeah if you go to
sleep without putting food there I'm not
gonna have not gonna have it yeah so
it's so I definitely do feel like they
that's there's more to them than just
brain yeah maybe
I think Stuart Hameroff is onto
something yeah about that but if you're
like in DES cuz I'm I've always been
really interested in birds particularly
um you know crows owls all that kind of
stuff but yeah mine too the Raven is
really good and this other book that I
got here this is in the kingdom of
gorillas and this is two people who live
on one of those gorilla sanctuaries like
in Africa and they're talking about the
gorillas that they hang out with and and
all that kind of stuff and I it's really
weird because I mean the one guy that
wrote the book they're a married couple
or you know whatever and they wrote this
and the one guy he actually got attacked
by a gorilla at some point it didn't
really hurt him all that bad I think
alike just bit him on the shoulder and
stuff like it hurt him but not you know
didn't maim him right and they were kind
of saying because I feel like you know
ever since maybe King Kong that people
have this misconception of gorillas as
really aggressive another chill which
they're actually not I mean they'll [ __ ]
you up if you [ __ ] with them
like if you get in their way or if you
make them mad and sit and and they point
out in this book that some of them like
just like people all of them have
different personalities they're like the
one that bit him was one that they knew
it wasn't surprising because they said
he was always kind of a dick that one so
it wasn't you know he had like a bad
temper so he's like you can tell like
just like you can with people like
gorillas are just the same like they all
have different personalities yeah and a
male chimp much worse than a gorilla
there oh yeah Envy that's it I saw an
interview with a guy who watched one of
them just eat another dude just eat him
up into pieces today in one of those
parks he said it was like looking into
the eyes of a [ __ ] demon that's how
sinister that thing was yeah they're
meanest [ __ ] man yeah yeah that was kind
of a wild type chimpanzee that was in a
park yeah Park Rangers knew him you know
and he just went he and a bunch of males
went on a rampage killed four or five
people well yeah and then there was that
one like remember that one lady that had
one for a pet unwisely yeah that tore
her [ __ ] face off or at or her
neighbor's face off oh god he got sick
of being locked up it's a lot of Chablis
you know they're not dumb well and the
sad thing is is that I think before
people knew that because I remember like
even like on Sesame Street and like all
of us like movies back in the 70s and
stuff um a lot of those that was the
same chimp because he was kind of like
famous you know what I mean and he'd
grown up like in a in a house with
people um but they're fine until I mean
they're real rambunctious obviously I
hit puberty but they're fine and the
males are fine the females are generally
more chilled out
I mean they'll [ __ ] you up too but the
males are way worse and once the males
get to about seven or eight years old
you can't I mean because they're like
way stronger than a person so it's like
if they're doing something you don't
like and you get up in their face
they'll just tear your arm right off you
know what I mean or tear your nuts right
off yeah or your face they're not that
much stronger than a human though pound
for pound the deal the the main
difference is they have a [ __ ]
tremendous bite force they just bite a
hand right off at the [ __ ] wrist
yeah just crunch a human can't do that
yeah but I used to think that they were
stronger than a human there
about as strong as a dude that works out
just that they don't they have a [ __ ]
a lot of rage and they can bite yeah
they're much much more powerful bite
than a human yes man they just bite your
face right off it's strange because
they're so closely related not only to
humans but they're also very closely
related to bonobos and bonobos are
pretty chill yeah I mean they've got a
strong sex drive well that's how they
that's how they've resolved all their
problems they just kind of come up and
instead of a handshake
well that's like I read a book about
bonobos and that's what they call a
bonobo handshake a bonobo will come up
and just like stick his penis somebody
was like hey you touch it like you just
gotta let it ride yes [ __ ] like that in
that damn Tiger King movie you'll see oh
it's like I said I really I really want
to talk about it but we can't because I
got to do it for the bat day show but
it's like [ __ ] here man there's this one
scene with this with the [ __ ] at a
Funeral [ __ ] went down a funeral I had
to get up and [ __ ] I just walk around
in a circle a just [ __ ] and going did
he [ __ ] do that did he really we were
just like no no said that she yeah this
is like I said they're all fun you just
got to see it
I mean he's the biggest lunatic but Joe
and they weren't playing no they were
serious it you see they're in a big old
[ __ ] tiger sanctuary there's like 200
[ __ ] big cats in it and they're all
running around armed you know just in
case cats get out of control they also
had people trying to get on a property
all the time and these dudes were just
nuts man you know I'm totally
comfortable around guns you know coming
up in the infantry there was nothing for
me to be around [ __ ] hundreds of
dudes with loaded weapons and then some
of their pointing at you sometimes
because no matter where you are you're
gonna point guns are pointed at people
just totally normal those dudes had no
no they had no business being around
guns or having gun
at least one of them at least one of
them the other one not meth not firearms
yeah
none of them [ __ ] needed to be around
god no or anything or anyone really yeah
it was and it wasn't just it wasn't just
confined to guns out vehicles anything
they shouldn't be allowed to clean I
better run fishing they're very funny
Tigers they shouldn't have been around
Alliance they should have been around
other human beings they just they should
have been in Florida there's all kinds
of [ __ ] it's just I love you like a
barge out the middle yeah dudes were a
[ __ ] mess they were a [ __ ] mess
man they're riding round four-wheelers
pretty nice pretty nice firearms you not
I mean in [ __ ] holsters and [ __ ] and
trying to put on the air of being a
professional and these dudes are just
[ __ ] lunatics man yeah they're around
they're mingling with the public you
know people come to see the Tigers and
they actually and in public they kind of
put on a decent show I guess you could
say of being sane but when the public
wasn't there if those people had known
really who who they were what they were
like they've never gonna know and it's
in the end I just really you'll see ya
in the end I just really felt bad for
the Tigers yeah more than anything I
just kind of wish they would eat
everyone yeah on the show that would
have been that would've been rad
actually the way that would like the
laughs just breaking that [ __ ] it we
hate you guys breaking every [ __ ]
every [ __ ] rule about how to comport
yourself of the fireman League pointing
loaded pistols at each other shooting
that man moving at them at each other
like as a joke as a joke just yeah just
ridiculous
yeah hilarious [ __ ] ridiculous oh you
winged my shin yeah yeah [ __ ] are
nuts man you're so funny what have you
learned you are and in the end I see
they are mostly a danger to themselves
but they're a danger to themselves yeah
you saw that mst3k
[Laughter]
danger to myself and others yeah alright
yeah so did you have anything else you
needed to do today any other yeah it's
any other messages anything yeah some of
these some of these governors are still
going around saying yeah we're gonna
stay locked out for 18 months no no you
know no it's just they they go work any
place that stays lockdown that long it's
gonna [ __ ] fall apart in two after
about folks after about two buds
and it's gonna be like escape from New
York or some [ __ ] like that nobody's
gonna stay lockdown that long I just see
these guys these governors on TV
grandstanding and all of them trying to
[ __ ] get brownie points a who who
values life the most and they're lying
so if you're in one of those areas where
man I'm gonna be locked up for 18 months
here not be able in my house no you're
not they're saying that and after a
couple of weeks when [ __ ] [ __ ] starts
going really bad they're gonna lift all
that [ __ ] ban or all those lockdowns
because they want to keep a city intact
I'm already seeing all the shining memes
what's it's like all the family and it's
like of all of them sitting there it's
like you know being locked away for the
few months just with just your family
with all though I'm kind of like you
know I've been working on for several
years so it's yeah but the thing is not
that way if you have a whole city like
that yeah and the economy isn't working
and the money's dry enough well yeah
that's it like that no [ __ ] way they
are trippin you're gonna have some
people going [ __ ] I'm leaving this
city yeah I mean they're gonna try to
leave they'll break quarantine and
they're gonna run into the police and
the police is gonna try to stop them say
no you can't leave the city and then the
next thing you know there's thousands of
them and a riot breaks out because they
all want to leave the city because
they've all been locked up for two
months and they're all out of money and
[ __ ] you know they can't afford food
anymore that kind of [ __ ] can go wrong
just cuz you give them money that
doesn't mean they're gonna have money
you're gonna give them money and
something gonna go all Broncs warriors
yeah you're gonna give you're gonna give
out money and there's gonna be a certain
percentage of those people that are just
like the people we were talking about
how to [ __ ] tiger King and they gonna
send signal spend that [ __ ] on meth okay
and then they're gonna get hungry and
you're gonna try to take other people's
[ __ ] it's just it just doesn't work out
it's gonna be like a Katrina type
situation well like I don't think it's
gonna get to that they're not gonna
they're not gonna let it get to that bed
and they're gonna realize that yeah all
the sick people are over here we'll keep
these kind of locks it down yeah you
guys over there yeah you can leave go
ahead
yeah go ahead and get out that's what
they're gonna do yeah they're not gonna
they're not gonna lock down the whole
country at a beautiful [ __ ]
somebody somebody commented on I guess
that when we put up our pandemic show
several weeks ago somebody commented
something about huh it's like oh how do
you feel that about like suckin up on
toilet paper I'm like [ __ ] we still got
toilet paper we bought before this hole
yes Arden yeah we saw a whole big thing
I looked there we go
I just went to public spam everything's
still there yeah Apple grocery store
they hid the canned goods in the [ __ ]
ended in Timor well I'm like you said
they even have like some paper products
I think when I went to Publix the other
day like I think the toilet paper was
still gone and the cleaning stuff was
gone like all the bleach and stuff but
other than that everything and then they
had you know all the fresh fruit and
vegetables in the [ __ ] world yeah
people aren't buying those because
they're like looking for stuff that's
gonna dry toilet paper
look if you're running out of toilet
paper just go get you a [ __ ] hose
look that hose up well I guess now you
think now is the time there's a it's a J
yeah get the bidet attached to just go
get your hose people get up do you sink
and turn that [ __ ] on sit over that
toilet just spray watch that [ __ ] off
clean it off tell the papers not the in
the world or like a paper wasn't around
forever that's a new invention or like
they said you just you know hop in the
shower yeah we were growing up it's like
sometimes if you couldn't afford like
disposable diapers you had to use cloth
diapers yeah that boy you don't want
that around no I know but it's like you
know what I mean if you know if a guy
dire emergency but man washing that and
having those [ __ ] things in your
house no yeah just get a [ __ ] hose
yeah hook it up to your sink that's what
I mean I feel like like a lot of people
who said just get a bidet attachment
like that
yeah and then spring you ass off spray
yes cuz like wolves everybody I know
that has bought one of those was like
it'll change your life it's the best
thing that's why you're at Brazil had
him they had the toilet and in a lot
yeah a lot of place in Europe added to
all those where I stay in the UK didn't
have one but like a lot of people don't
have them yeah they're just like you
just took a shower bring little sparkles
on bouncing off yeah there's some reason
I just thought of like a red & stimpy
cartoon like little but like people
[ __ ] over my whole house away and I
could live well yeah I live down a field
in the army [ __ ] months on end
sometimes long so I got my rock and all
my equipment some bungee cord and a
poncho liner and [ __ ] whoopee I don't
know if this was the origin of it but um
cuz it might have been a thing before
that but I always called it a whoopee
because of mr. mum that Michael Keaton
movie from 1982 or I just call it that
because civilians wouldn't know what a
poncho liner was yeah well Whoopi's a
blanket - blanket yeah but a poncho
liners apply because that was what his
kid called like his security blanket
yeah Bobby in the army if you carried a
blanket David just call you a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
alright then we had a thing called a
poncho liner you have a regular poncho
which you can stick your head through
alright and it rings around it and snaps
well in those little rings you can put
you can put bungee cord and stretch it
out and make it tense Coby used to call
the hooch and get underneath there
alright well you can also attach that
poncho liner poncho to a liner and turn
into like a waterproof blanket but only
a pug would do that yeah we keep kept
the liner separate so you get underneath
your shelter and then you roll up you
know the man then you wrap your poncho
around you poncho line around you and if
you were really gonna set up a [ __ ]
four-star hotel you get out your damn
inflatable mattress alright because we
had the fladeboe mattress and we also
have thing called [ __ ] pad which is
just a foam rubber mat you can get on
that then you can put your sleeping bag
on it but if you had an inflatable
mattress that's even better I got one of
yeah just blow it up cuz that'll raise
you up off the ground a couple of inches
that well Stephen bag won't get wet if
it rain if the water starts yeah yeah
yes they're meant to be rainin and
[ __ ] the rain wouldn't be on me and
we could be in Korea and all the rain
would [ __ ] be going down through your
hood like you're sleeping in the center
of a waterfall and you'd mean [ __ ]
dried [ __ ] on that inflatable mattress
just about there just looking at the
water going
yeah well walk look at the water gone by
smoking to the dude next to you yeah I
just left and I didn't know if you knew
that that's where that came from
nah you know I know I don't well I don't
know like I said I don't know if it was
a thing before that but that's that's
where I got it from okay it's because
that's what I just called it a whoo
that's what his kid called his security
blanket yes it is a security blanket yes
cuz I haven't seen that movie in a long
time but I remember he somehow Michael
Keaton because the whole premise if mr.
mom which seems like a really weird
sexist premise is in this day and age it
was like that men are clueless about how
to do anything like around the house or
how many do the children anything I
don't know how to cook I don't know like
iron anything and [ __ ] like to have
which is very silly but um it was still
a funny movie but I think he he [ __ ]
the whoopee up somehow like Islands he
actually probably knowing him you
probably like accidentally put it in the
blender or some [ __ ] like that it was
like stupid
so I remember he had a like staple
staple of the [ __ ] together and I
remember him making grilled cheese
sandwiches with the iron jammies kind of
wanted to do then I was like nah I
probably would be a good idea you could
make it with a waffle iron
ya Dums he's over to iron yeah never
clothes iron he was make like on the
iron like too hard to put the pan I
guess that's a really sexist because
this like talking about stupid bet are
they don't know maybe one of these days
on a bust and all that equipment tell
people show people how to use all that
stuff yeah maybe you can do that
tomorrow on tomorrow sure yeah maybe if
you want explain everybody what
you spleen it i'll splaying it tom
explains it all you can make a video
okay maybe yes I'll do that tomorrow if
you feel like it alright he's probably
not gonna feel like it all right so uh
tomorrow we got a movie review going up
and we'll have another one of these to
you it'll go up in the afternoon so
we'll talk to you guys again then